und jetzt das heute journal
[Musik]
mit heinz wolf und christian sievers
guten abend hinein barcelona ist eines
der beliebtesten ziele für städtereisen
weltweit aber selbst wer schon oft dort
war wird diese stadt heute abend kaum
wiedererkennen der eine teil wie
verwaist generalstreik der andere in
aufregung und aufruhr massenproteste
barcelona hat 1,7 millionen einwohner im
moment sind mehr als eine halbe million
menschen dort auf der straße
anhänger der katalanischen
unabhängigkeitsbewegung empört über die
langen haftstrafen die ein spanisches
gericht verhängt hat gegen neun
separatistenführer das war anfang der
woche und seitdem legen streiks und
demos abend für abend halb katalonien
lahm
die situation aktuell von christel haas
es fliegen wieder steine wieder brennen
straßenbarrikaden
auch dieser abend in barcelona endet mit
gewalt die randalierer zeigen auf ihre
weise was sie vom spanischen
ministerpräsidenten halten
der hatte am nachmittag deutliche worte
gefunden
dann werden alle die für gewalttaten
verantwortlich sind identifizieren und
vor gericht stellen damit sie die strafe
bekommen die sie verdienen
es war der protest heute in barcelona er
beginnt mit einem generalstreik viele
geschäfte sind dicht manche aus
solidarität manche aus angst vor
randalierern einige schließen andere
nicht aber dass wir so viele auf die
straße bringen ist doch schon ein erfolg
am nachmittag strömen hunderttausende
katalanen in die stadt sie alle eint die
empörung sie alle fordern die
freilassung der verurteilten
separatistenführer und wieder einmal die
unabhängigkeit
es gibt politische gefangene in europa
das ist unverzeihlich da müssen wir auf
die straße gehen
wir fordern unsere rechte ein und vor
allem die unabhängigkeit wir fordern
demokratie vor dem polizeihauptquartier
fliegen derweil schon eier und andere
lebensmittel in richtung der
sicherheitskräfte nicht jeder hier
verurteilt die gewalt der letzten tage
viele junge leute sind politisch
frustriert und ihre weise das
herauszulassen ist die gewalt die fünfte
krawallnacht die katalanische regierung
hatte zwar die gewalt verurteilt aber
gleichzeitig öl ins feuer gegossen
sie fordert ein neues referendum selbst
wenn wir für ein
unabhängigkeitsreferendum zu 100 jahren
verurteilt werden
wir müssen wieder über die
unabhängigkeit abstimmen und genau das
fordern sie heute lautstark die
katalonien krise geht in eine neue runde
und nichts deutet auf entspannung hin
also rechtlich ist die lage klar es darf
keine rezession geben aber das löst das
politische problem natürlich nicht
das kann die rechtsordnung nicht lösen
ist eine politische initiative und
vielleicht eine originelle lösung
gefordert
die aber von beiden seiten mit getragen
werden mussten
bis eine solche originelle lösung
gefunden ist wird es wohl eher so
weitergehen mit massivem polizeiaufgebot
brennenden barrikaden und gewalt wenn es
in unseren redaktionskonferenzen hier um
die frage geht welche themen in diese
sendung kommen dann gibt es ein argument
das zieht immer es ist der satz das
thema betrifft jeden in deutschland und
deshalb erklärt ihnen dalian teil jetzt
was sie wissen sollten zum thema
grundsteuer da ändert sich nämlich
einiges es ist nicht ganz einfach aber
egal ob man zur miete wohnt oder im
eigenen haus erst betrifft jeden und sie
werden das merken auf dem konto schon
die alten römer mussten von ihrem geld
steuern auf ihren grundbesitz zahlen die
grundsteuer ist einer der ältesten
steuern überhaupt seit dem mittelalter
wurde sie auch in deutschland erhoben
heute spielt die grundsteuer den städten
und gemeinden etwa 14 milliarden euro
jährlich in die kassen bezahlt wird sie
von wohnungs und hausbesitzer die die
kosten allerdings an die mieter
weitergeben dürfen
die grundsteuer basiert auf dem wert
eines grundstücks grundlage für die
berechnung der grundsteuer sind bislang
die sogenannten einheitswerte in
westdeutschland wurden sie zuletzt 1964
festgelegt in ostdeutschland basieren
sie sogar auf werken von 1935 nicht mehr
zeitgemäß wie ein beispiel zeigt zwei
grundstücke mit einem einfamilienhaus
können vor jahrzehnten gleich viel wert
gewesen sein sich heute aber im wert
deutlich unterscheiden was vorher
stadtrand war kann heute begehrtes
wohnviertel sein
trotzdem zahlen beide eigentümer gleich
viel grundsteuer ein umstrittener
einheitswert den das
bundesverfassungsgericht für
verfassungswidrig erklärt hat am zehnten
april 2018 entschieden die richter
bis ende 2019 muss eine neuregelung her
ja und ende 2019 das ist bald da sitzt
das höchste gericht also dem gesetzgeber
ganz schön im nacken
er hat lange gerungen vor allem mit den
ländern und heute dann aber grünes licht
gegeben für die reform der grundsteuer
in diesem land rund 35 millionen
grundstücke müssen neu bewertet werden
da kommt eine lawine zu auf die
verwaltung aus berlin david gebhard das
erste haus am platz nutzfläche 11.000
quadratmeter wassergrundstück citylage
das reichstagsgebäude eine viele
immobilie
doch als eigentum des bundes von der
grundsteuer befreit
im gebäude wird heute das neue
grundsteuer gesetz beschlossen das vom
villen besitzer bis mieter alle betrifft
und sein urheber große worte wählen
lässt über das gesetz und sich das ist
eine große leistung der demokratie dass
das gelungen ist es wirklich eine große
leistung von allen zusammen und ich bin
sehr froh darüber dass sich als
bundesminister der finanzen mit all den
erfahrungen die ich in unserem föderalen
staat auch als ehemaliger bürgermeister
hatte alles dafür tun konnte dass es
jetzt klappt von alleine wäre das nicht
gegangen
gut eineinhalb jahre haben die parteien
gerungen und verhandelt nun ein
kompromiss
die grundsteuer wird neuberechnet es
zählen künftig etwa das baujahr der
gebäude der aktuelle bodenrichtwert und
die kaltmiete gleichzeitig kommt per
grundgesetzänderung eine
länderöffnungsklausel bayern zb will in
einem flächen modell lediglich die größe
des grundstücks und gebäudes zur
berechnung heranziehen
wir haben hier eine situation dass es in
deutschland relativ schnell einen
flickenteppich geben kann
wir sind insgesamt mit dieser einigung
nicht zufrieden weil niemand jetzt genau
weiß was passiert denn genau mit meiner
immobilie ein hauptkritikpunkt ist
eigentlich aber dass es wirklich zu
kompliziert ist umgesetzt zu werden in
der praxis und wie das ist ein
steuererhöhungs automatismus ist es gibt
darin die werte wurden richtwerte und
auch die miet werte die steigen nun mal
von zeit zu zeit und dann ist es wie
eine kalte progression auf die
grundsteuer die kommunen selbst legen
die genaue höhe der steuer fest durch
individuelle hebesätze
immobilienbesitzer dürfen die
grundsteuer an ihre mieter weitergeben
wer künftig mehr zahlt und wer weniger
ist noch nicht klar
die gemeinden werden ihr steueraufkommen
nicht durch diese reformen erhöhen
da kann man ganz sicher sein alle haben
das zu vorher gesagt und versprochen und
ich bin auch sicher dass man sich darauf
verlassen kann
klar ist aber auch dass das gesetz was
heute verabschiedet worden ist dieses
versprechen nicht einlösen kann
die bundespolitik braucht die kommunen
die kommunen legen hebesätze fest und
die kommunen sind aufgefordert die
hebesätze zu senken damit die
grundsteuer belastung nicht höher wird
erhoben wird die neue grundsteuer ab
2025 in gut drei wochen soll sie noch
durch den bundesrat
übrigens auch ein gebäude in toplagen
potsdamer platz und grundsteuern frei
und wir haben noch weitere wichtige
entscheidungen im parlament heute heinz
hat den überblick
eine dieser entscheidungen betrifft das
wohngeld für geringverdiener
es soll ab kommendem jahr mehr menschen
zugute kommen die bundesregierung geht
davon aus dass rund 660.000 haushalte
entlastet werden 180.000 mehr als bisher
und das wohngeld wird auch erhöht um
durchschnittlich 30 prozent noch nicht
entschieden aber beraten wurde heute
über eine impfpflicht gegen masern in
kitas und schulen
der gesetzentwurf sieht vor dass eltern
nachweisen müssen dass ihre kinder
geimpft oder immun sind bevor sie in der
kita oder der schule aufgenommen werden
auch für das personal dort soll diese
pflicht gelten ebenso für beschäftigte
in medizinischen einrichtungen bei
verstößen drohen bußgelder in einer
moschee im osten afghanistans sind
während des freitagsgebets mehrere
bomben explodiert das dach des
gotteshauses stürzte ein und dabei
wurden mindestens 62 menschen getötet
36 weitere wurden verletzt in der
betroffenen provinz nangahar sind
militante islamistische taliban sowie
die terra milizen es aktiv bislang hat
sich aber niemand zu dem anschlag
bekannt
im libanon bis heute den zweiten tag in
folge große proteste gegen die regierung
und zum teil schwere
auseinandersetzungen zwischen
demonstranten und sicherheitskräften
auf beiden seiten soll es zahlreiche
verletzte gegeben
die protestierenden fordern den
rücktritt der regierung und maßnahmen
gegen die wirtschaftskrise im land
die innenminister von bund und ländern
ziehen erste konsequenzen aus dem
anschlag in halle
sie haben auf einer sonderkonferenz in
berlin eine reihe von maßnahmen
beschlossen so sollen jüdische
einrichtungen künftig besser geschützt
werden
außerdem wurde vereinbart eine stärkere
zusammenarbeit der behörden ein verbot
von extremistischen vereinen und
veranstaltungen anbieter von internet
plattformen müssen strafrechtlich
relevante inhalte melden und löschen und
eine verschärfung des waffenrechts
verfassungsschutzpräsident heilen bank
sieht den flügel innerhalb der afg
weiterhin als verdachtsfall halten sagte
dem spiegel in einem interview der
flügel sei vor mehreren monaten als
verdachtsfall eingestuft worden und zu
halten dann weiter wir sehen nichts was
uns von dieser einschätzung ab bringen
würde im gegenteil der flügel wird immer
extremistischer und der
verfassungsschutz präsident äusserte
sich auch zu gefahren durch den konflikt
in nordsyrien der könnte laut halten
bank auch dazu führen dass ausländische
kämpfer aus den gefängnissen freikommen
und nach europa zurückkehren
es soll auch bereits ausbruchsversuche
von es anhängern gegeben haben wie
diesem lager vor einigen tagen die
bewachung der lager könnte unmittelbar
durch kämpfe erschwert werden oder weil
kurdische kräfte ihre position dort
verlassen um sich an kämpfen zu
beteiligen oder aus dem gebiet
abzuziehen
wir bleiben im moment bei der lage in
nordsyrien man muss die kinder im hof
auch mal laufen lassen
lasst sie kämpfen und dann ziehst du sie
wieder auseinander an diesen
erziehungsrat von vorgestern präsentiert
der präsident der vereinigten staaten
jetzt als seine strategie im umgang mit
dem pulverfass nordsyrien
[Applaus]
es ist nicht lustig wenn überall kugeln
fliegen aber wir sind hin und haben
gesagt wir wollen eine pause die kurden
werden sich ein bisschen zurückziehen
und wir werden den es schön eingesperrt
lassen
das ist trump uhr problem gelöst so will
er sich den jubelnden anhängern zeigen
die wahrheit allerdings ist deutlich
komplizierter trumps laufende kinder im
hof haben bereits jetzt hunderte
menschenleben auf ihrem gewissen und
über 100000 unschuldige die fliehen
mussten über sie vom präsidenten kein
wort zur wahrheit gehört auch ob drums
waffenpause für nordsyrien überhaupt
funktioniert ist alles andere als sicher
luckwald berichtet heftige explosionen
maschinengewehrfeuer heute in ras allein
die kurdische seite wirft der türkischen
armee vor die waffenruhe gebrochen und
die stadt unter beschuss genommen zu
haben
ankara dementiert dass über einen
hilfskonvoi mit medikamenten und
nahrungsmitteln berichten kurdische
medien der wegen der kämpfe nicht in die
stadt konnte wir bräuchten dringend
einen humanitären korridor um alte und
verletzte aus dem kampfgebiet zu bringen
auf türkischer seite verlegt die armee
weiter truppen und gerät an die grenze
die offensive ist für ankara erst
beendet wenn eine türkisch kontrollierte
zone auf einer länge von 440 kilometern
erobert wurde
das unterstrich präsident erdogan noch
einmal am abend wenn die usa ihr
versprechen einhalten ist die frage der
sicherheitszone gelöst geschieht das
nicht werden wir unsere militär
operation noch intensiver verführen die
gestern ausgehandelte vereinbarung
enthält aber keine details darüber wie
groß die sogenannte sicherheitszone sein
soll
so kann jede seite das papier als vollen
erfolg für sich verbuchen
washington jedenfalls hat eine ganz
eigene version
deren kurdischen kräfte ziehen sich
innerhalb von fünf tagen aus den
gebieten zurück wo die türken jetzt sind
nach dem rückzug stoppt die türkei alle
militäroperationen in nordost syrien
die kurdischen milizen haben schon klar
gemacht dass nur über täler glatte und
rastern ein gesprochen wurde und nur aus
diesem grenzabschnitt wollen sie sich
zurückziehen
aus brüssel kam erneut scharfe kritik
sowohl an der türkischen offensive als
auch an der vereinbarung mit den usa
diese sogenannte feuerpause ist weniger
eine feuerpause als vielmehr ein
kapitulation south liefern die kurse
demonstrativ traf sich syriens
machthaber assad heute in damaskus mit
dem russischen sonderbeauftragten von
präsident putin am dienstag wird putin
dann in sotschi erdogan empfangen und
die wohl erklären wie weit man gewillt
ist ihm entgegenzukommen
in der türkischen grenzstadt akl
jedenfalls wird die waffenruhe sehr
begrüßt die vereinbarungen von präsident
erdogan ist sehr gut ich glaube sie
zwingt diese pkk leute in die knie
der teufel liegt er bei solchen dingen
immer im detail und die zeit läuft fünf
tage dann soll läuft diese waffenruhe
wieder aus am dienstag soll sie also
schon wieder vorbei sein wenn sie
überhaupt angefangen hat das versuchen
wir jetzt raus zu finden mit thomas gill
er ist an der türkisch syrischen grenze
auf türkischer seite thomas guten abend
es gibt ja unterschiedliche aussagen
über die wirkung einer waffenpause hat
sie denn bei den menschen die es ja
wirklich in erster linie angeht zu
entscheidenden verbesserungen geführt
oder gehen die gefechte doch weiter als
in den letzten stunden ist es hier ruhig
und das erst mal ein gutes signal für
die menschen in der region
die haben es noch eine kurze atempause
zumindest was man sagen muss das aber am
morgen
in der umgebung von ras allein das haben
wir gerade gesehen da gab es so heftige
gefechte
und mit zahlreichen toten auch unter den
unter den zivilisten mit etlichen
verletzten auch und wie beide seiten
haben sich jetzt da gegenseitig
beschuldigt diese diese die die
verletzung der waffenpause hier
gefährdet zu haben und das zeigt
sozusagen auch jetzt wie gefährdet und
wie zerbrechlich diese feuerpause hier
ist und wie häufig bei solchen dingen
ist ja dann vieles umstritten jede seite
hat so was wie ihre eigene sicht auf die
dinge worüber wir da genau reden und das
macht das natürlich nicht einfacher wo
sind denn die haupt knackpunkte der
haupt der eigentliche knackpunkt ist aus
welchem gebiet sich die kunden denn
eigentlich zurückziehen sollen also für
sie selbst ist das relativ klar sie
haben gesagt dass sie sich in einem aus
einem gebiet zurückziehen werden von
etwa 120 kilometern das haben sie
akzeptiert aber erdogan will dass sie
sich eben entlang der gesamten
türkischen syrischen grenze eben
zurückziehen
er hat davon vier über 440 kilometern
gesprochen und das problem ist dass die
groß diese sogenannten pufferzone den
tatsächlich ist das steht nicht in
diesem abkommen drin und das macht das
eigentliche problem aus und darüber gibt
es eine menge streit was wir hier noch
erfahren haben dass jetzt wohl die
ersten syrisch kurdischen milizen sich
zurückgezogen haben bekam vorhin die
meldung dass das auch das türkische
verteidigungsministerium bestätigt hat
aber unklar ist ob auch die waffen die
schweren waffen zurückgelassen wurden
das ist noch nicht klar und das wird man
dann erst bald sehen also während der
us-präsident vollzug und erfolg meldet
gibt es doch noch eine ganze menge
banken bei denen die es angeht vor ort
thomas gill herzlichen dank und damit
zurück zu uns nach deutschland wenn sich
jemand zum zweiten mal im selben jahr
zur wahl stellt als vorsitzender seiner
partei
dann kann er sich entweder sehr sicher
im sattel fühlen oder
sehr unsicher bei markus söder dürfen
wir ersteres annehmen der mann hat eine
erstaunliche image wandlung hinter sich
plötzlich betont ausgleichend mit großem
herz für die umwelt
jetzt will auch seiner partei eine
erneuerungskurs verpassen und da kommt
ihm das wahlergebnis von 91,3 prozent
gerade recht dass es mehr als beim
letzten mal
man muss allerdings dazu sagen einen
gegenkandidaten hatte sünder nicht der
parteitag der csu eine traditionspartei
die durchstarten soll richtung zukunft
weil ihr chef es so will
jürgen wollmann berichtet die
erleichterung ist ihm anzumerken
den kurswechsel den markus söder von
seiner partei verlangt haben die
delegierten angenommen 91,3 prozent
wählen ihn erneut zum vorsitzenden
die csu müsse um ihre zukunft als
volkspartei kämpfen so markus söder
wie alle anderen parteien auch ich sage
gerne die herausforderung für uns ist in
veränderten zeiten politische führung zu
zeigen
ich möchte dass die csu schritt mache
ist und nicht nur anderen hinterher lauf
muslime freundin das muss unser anspruch
sein denn wir als csu in deutschland in
bayern erfüllen wollen jünger und
weiblicher soll die csu werden so wird
die frauenquote auch auf untere
parteigremien wie kreisverbände
ausgedehnt die quote immer noch ein
reizthema der csu was mir zu viel ist
das jetzt vielleicht überraschendste
frauen wurde weil ich persönlich von der
frauenquote nichts halte vor allen
dingen möchte in dieser intensität zehn
jahre politik erfahrung hat mich gelehrt
es gibt es verbände wo es eine quote
braucht weil einfach die gesellschaft in
manchen bereichen noch nicht so weit ist
kritik aber vor allem am tempo mit dem
sie über die parteireform auf den weg
gebracht hat ich bin mitglied in einem
csu kreisvorstand und ich bin mitglied
im bezirksvorstand
ich habe von dieser reform von den
verhandlungen geführt worden sind
eigentlich nichts mitbekommen
alles steht plötzlich auf dem prüfstand
die politische inhalte und auch das
erscheinungsbild näher am menschen
gehört jetzt zum neuen logo der partei
der parteitag eine grundsatzdiskussion
im schnellgang die csu auf der suche
nach neuen werten und einem neuen image
denn wir leben heute in einer anderen
welt als früher
ich bin fest überzeugt so leicht gibt es
kein zurück mehr die gute alte zeit
denn die demokratie auch in unserem land
hat sich verändert in deutschland der
demokratische boden vibriert wie tief
der einschnitt für die traditionspartei
csu ist zeigt geradezu symbolisch die
einstellung der parteizeitung
bayernkurier zum jahresende das
parteiblatt gegründet von franz josef
strauß eine ikone für viele in der csu
das gesparte geld soll in die partei
erneuerung fließen
söder muss jetzt erreichen dass ihm
seine partei bei diesem erneuerungs
tempo auch weiterhin folgt wir haben
nochmal nachrichten nochmals mit der
neuen runde im transatlantischen
handelsstreit spricht den strafzöllen in
höhe von 25 prozent die die usa heute
auf zahlreiche produkte aus europa
erlassen haben weil er hunger welche
produkte trifft es und wie kommt es
überhaupt zu einem solchen streit mit
diesen mitteln
ja also anders als bei den
amerikanischen zöllen auf stahl hält
sich donald trump diesmal an die regeln
der welthandelsorganisation sie hat
nämlich grünes licht gegeben dafür weil
sie festgestellt hat dass die europäer
den flugzeugbauer airbus jahre lang
rechtswidrig subventioniert haben diesen
trumpf spielt der us präsident nun aus
pro jahr siebeneinhalb milliarden dollar
strafzölle auf bestimmte europäische
produkte in das trifft neben deutschland
vor allem frankreich großbritannien und
spanien also jene länder die für die
airbus staatshilfen verantwortlich sind
die auswirkungen spüren werden vor allem
mittelständische betriebe mit zöllen in
höhe von 25 prozent belegt werden wein
und whisky aus frankreich großbritannien
und deutschland käse aus italien und den
niederlanden
früchte und muscheln aus spanien
baumaschinen und optische teile aus
deutschland durch die zölle dürften die
europäischen waren in den usa deutlich
teuerer werden brüssel droht mit
vergeltung denn auch die usa haben ihren
flugzeugbauer boeing staatlich
unterstützt eine entscheidung ob auch
die eu strafzölle erheben darf steht
noch aus celle gegen celle ähnlich hat
sich der handel streit zwischen den usa
und china hochgeschaukelt keine gute
nachricht für den welthandel valerie
haller
vielen dank in der fußball-bundesliga
hat der achte spieltag begonnen am abend
und da spielte eintracht frankfurt gegen
bayer leverkusen frankfurt hat gewonnen
gerade eben mit 3 zu 0 bei den bahnrad
europameisterschaften im
niederländischen apeldoorn ist am abend
franziska pause bei der 3000 meter
einerverfolgung auf den ersten platz
gefahren
die 20-jährige aus passion brown setzte
sich mit einer persönlichen bestzeit von
3 minuten 25 überraschend gegen
titelverteidigerin lisa brennauer durch
die hatten in der qualifikation noch
einen neuen deutschen rekord aufgestellt
konnte die leistung im finale aber nicht
wiederholen und damit sagt das
heute-journal team danke für ihr
interesse und empfiehlt ihnen jetzt
matthias fornoff der hat nämlich
brandneue zahlen vom zdf politbarometer
sind
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer
wo ein wille ist da ist ein deal
twitterte eu-kommissionschef juncker als
das neue austritts abkommen zwischen
brüssel und london
auf dem tisch lag die staats und
regierungschefs haben dem zugestimmt
ob boris johnson den deal im britischen
parlament durch bekommt ist aber alles
andere als sicher
viele briten sind von der bresse
dauerschleife frustriert und die
deutschen den austritt großbritanniens
finden neun prozent gut 65 prozent
schlecht 24 prozent der befragten sagen
dass ihnen der austritt egal ist
wesentlich mehr als noch vor drei wochen
da war auch der anteil derer die den
braxton schlecht finden deutlich höher
die sehnsucht nach einem ende in brechts
drama scheint gestiegen morgen
entscheidet das unterhaus an einem
anderen schauplatz geht es um das
schicksal tausender kunden auf den abzug
der us-truppen aus nordsyrien folgte der
einmarsch des türkischen militärs
seitdem wird auch in deutschland über
sanktionen gegen die türkei diskutiert
dass deutschland wirtschaftssanktionen
gegen die türkei verhängen sollte
befürworten 65 prozent der befragten 27
prozent sind dagegen
eine deutliche mehrheit von 91 prozent
ist der meinung dass keine waffen mehr
an den nato-partner geliefert werden
sollten
auch international hagelte es kritik am
vorgehen des türkischen präsidenten
johann drohte im gegenzug der eu er
könne millionen flüchtlingen die tür
nach europa öffnen
80 prozent der befragten glauben dass
die türkei bei sanktionen das
flüchtlings abkommen beenden wird und
dann wieder mehr menschen nach europa
kommen 15 prozent glauben das nicht
jetzt soll es eine mehrtägige feuerpause
in nordsyrien geben
die nächsten tage werden zeigen wie
ernst es den akteuren damit ist die
außenpolitik beherrschte in dieser woche
das politische berlin damit rückt das
thema klima etwas in den hintergrund
wohl auch deshalb geben die grünen
punkte ab die regierungsparteien legen
zu wenn am nächsten sonntag wirklich
bundestagswahl wäre käme die cdu csu auf
29 prozent plus 2 die spd erreichte 14
prozent plus 1 die fdp erhielte 13
prozent minus 1 die fdp 6 und verändert
die linke 8 prozent plus 1 und die
grünen erhielten 24 prozent minus 3
damit hätte weiterhin eine koalition aus
cdu csu und grünen als einziges
realistisches bündnis eine klare
mehrheit
die amtierende große koalition darf sich
kurz vor ihrer halbzeit bilanz über
gestiegene zustimmungswerte freuen
in unserer top ten also der bewertung
der wichtigsten politikerinnen und
politiker gibt es in dieser woche viele
gewinner nur zwei verlierern
auf einer skala von +5 bis -5 ist
annegret kramp karrenbauer schlusslicht
verliert leicht minus 0,6 ihr bisher
schlechteste wert platz neun für horst
seehofer er gewinnt leicht minus 0,2
davor ursula von der leyen mit gewinnen
minus 0,1 markus söder unverändert 0,1
platz sechs für christian lindner
leichte verluste 0,1 davor heiko maas
legte 0,9 olaf scholz mit deutlichen
gewinnen 1,1 platz drei für robert
habeck ebenfalls verbessert 1,2 platz
zwei für angela merkel mit gewinnen 1,6
und platz eins für winfried kretschmann
auch er gewinnt leicht hinzu 1,9
eineinhalb wochen nach dem anschlag auf
eine synagoge in halle und zwei toten
sitzt der schock noch tief
deutschland diskutiert über politische
konsequenzen und darüber wie es zu der
gewalttat kommen konnte
dabei geht es auch um den vorwurf dass
die afd
durch ihre positionen und aussagen eine
mitschuld an rechtsextremen gewalttaten
trägt 72 prozent der befragten sagen
dass dieser vorwurf zutrifft
21 prozent sehen das nicht so in fast
allen anhängergruppen gibt es hier sehr
hohe zustimmungswerte nur bei den fdp
anhängern ist der wert mit fünf prozent
sehr niedrig mehr als drei viertel der
deutschen finden dass nicht genug gegen
rechtsextreme ansichten und
gruppierungen getan wird
eine zentrale forderung nach den morden
in halle lautet jüdisches leben in
deutschland muss besser geschützt werden
generell hat sich die einschätzung zum
antisemitismus deutlich verändert das
ist in deutschland eine große oder sogar
sehr große judenfeindlichkeit gibt
glauben 38 prozent der befragten im
februar waren es nur 17 prozent
experten weisen schon lange darauf hin
dass angriffe auf juden zu nehmen
wie berechtigt das ist hat halle auf
grausame weise gezeigt das war unser
bericht über die stimmung im land die
grafiken und alle informationen zu
unseren umfragen finden sie wie immer im
zdf text ab seite 165 und auf heute.de
wie die repräsentativen umfragen der
forschungsgruppe wahlen zustande kommen
informationen zur methodik und zu den
qualitätsstandards finden sie unter
politbarometer punkt zdf.de vielen dank
für ihr interesse
das nächste politbarometer gibt es dann
am 8 november
hier geht's nach dem wetter weiter mit
der heute-show ihnen noch einen
entspannten freitagabend und ein schönes
wochenende auch wieder sehen
[Musik]
und amtliche zuschauer für viele von
ihnen wird es morgen auch ziemlich nass
werden wir haben eine südwestströmung
mit der eben immer wieder diese
regengebiete über uns hinweg ziehen
heftige schauer und gewitter gegen an
dieser kette die jetzt deutschland
langsam verlässt aber dass ein neues
regengebiet das uns erreicht schon in
der zweiten nachthälfte aber noch in
recht milder luft anders auf dem
atlantik da haben es ziemlich kalt bis
zur iberischen halbinsel und trägt jetzt
auch kräftig letzte schauer noch
vielleicht über der ostsee ziehen die
jetzt langsam ab dann haben wir das erst
mal trocken aber der zweiten nachthälfte
zieht von südwesten neuer regen auf und
der wird dann sozusagen am vormittag
weiter ziehen richtung thüringen sachsen
brandenburg im norden kann die sonne
raus kommen genauso wie südlich der
donau da wird es freundlich mit
sonnenschein das bleibt dann auch am
nachmittag so da ändert sich eigentlich
nichts während sonst der regen im westen
auch schleswig holstein erreicht wir
haben einen kräftigen südwind dazu und
der regen im osten zieht auch langsam
hoch richtung oder und vorpommern vor
allen dingen in dem späten nachmittag
wird es auch hier im südwesten im
schwarzwald wieder kräftiger anfangen zu
regnen
bei den temperaturen ändert sich wenig
12 bis 17 grad haben wir meist aber hier
südlich der donau südöstlichen bayern
bis zu 20 grad der sonntag bringt uns
noch mehr wärme auch in den osten und
vor allen dingen im süden mit viel
sonnenschein aber hier im nordwesten
wird es kräftig regnen
in der nächsten woche tja da wird sich
das wetter langsam beruhigen dienst doch
am mittwoch haben wir keinen regen mehr
sonne und wolken wechseln sich wünschen
noch einen schönen abend und machen
sie's gut